okay so if we look at his arm I know I
know we can't stand there because he has
the
he has the spine on his face so I can't
I can't stay in place
and uh he's inside my shoulder well that
means my arm is outside my shoulder okay
and then he doesn't have a joint here on
the outside
okay
in fact this is where I would boom I
might try for a break or something
so coming here on the outside and trying
to bend his arm is not going to happen
and even if you pay attention
Okay if you pay attention this joint is
not exactly
uh totally on on the 90 on the outside
it's kind of diagonally down do you see
that which means there's really no hinge
and it hurts really hard there's really
no hinge there either
see I don't know if you could pull this
up
here's here's the fold of his elbow
right there
there's no hinge here
so when my arm comes from the outside
there's not there's no way I can bend
that arm
okay usually what happens is
so uh
I know I have to move so I have to move
just like always you see and that's that
void that is your chance to uh reconcile
your fears that you'll keep your spinal
displacing okay so I have to move so
that I'm at his uh we call that zero
pressure right he said he he he's not
I'm right at the edge you get it so for
example if I'm in here he's still got
some
if I'm all outside of it then it doesn't
work you have to be at a zero question
okay so that's there and what I'm going
to do is come to the come to the inside
okay and you can see that there's you
were asking me what am I feeling for I
feel this tension right there
do you see this this tension right there
is not going to be right okay so can you
see it in my shoulder right here okay
and if you pay attention
uh uh yeah he knows he I'm not at I'm
not at zero pressure I'm a little shy of
it so just kind of go like that you see
so
find that tension and look how I maybe
have to go to the inside let me see
maybe I have to go to the inside and
then I'm on I'm on where the joint is to
joined us here
the joints did
[Music]
so like swordwork
I'm on the inside okay and then don't
ask for a lot of this
my goal here is only to get some tilt
that I can pick up and let go of the arm
because
here oh
you understand hey so maybe it's all
as you're going
uh you saw that one where he started to
pull me down
you're pushing down here it's like does
it make sense push down on the thing
that he's pushing down when you're like
whoa okay so you're you're going to uh
come in and off
I'll just stick with one side so you can
see it so boom boom
so back to Chris's question I'm feeling
for
where I don't feel him really
okay
so to give a concrete example as
I feel that I started to pull that I go
you're too late coming off of it
do you see
okay
right
so there's your arm right so I'm I'm
gonna go here
I'm on the inside
and then this part turns
excuse me that's what I'm doing
so I'm not on the house I'm not on the
top
and then cranking it in and then doing
something I'm on the inside and I'm
going this way
okay all right put it down to the other
one let's say that I I tried I'm like oh
no oh no you see that mistake you see
that and I don't think I'm gonna I don't
think I can do it it happens
so going back to like the cues that
you're saying the Sensei what do you
feel for to tell you not that way this
way okay so let's say I feel that okay I
just could let go of it and change the
second
so what is letting go of so I feel like
whoa that's really strong you see and
then I neutralize it
[Music]
foreign
you see and you push and not pushing on
her that's grounding you see so she
pushes
and it's just grounding
that that's what you're hitting her with
okay
did you get what I was trying to
demonstrate yes that would have been
your head coming in boom and you hit
like a solid wall okay so as you come
around don't expect like you're you're
gonna do something unless you're
internalizing it so
[Music]
all right
now I kind of made a little fun okay try